baby backs  I wish you  oh geez my powers will become yours wait  for you okay  [Music]  that's crazy right what are your  superpowers simmer for hours dude I  don't even know how to pee in this thing  [Music]  electricity manipulation  hyperspeed I'd like to purchase some of  your finest beer please  [Music]  is Kathy Sparkle fingers no it's not  it's not money that's not my name chosen  one like a bad guy you really did the  opposite of what a superhero supposed to  do you're him you're the hero  I will do basically 15  [Music]  see that yeah you electrocuted a bus and  almost kill these people and then I  caught it  leap tall buildings in a single bound  you